ينضم الينا من عمان لواء فايز الدويل
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه اهلا بك
معنا نبدا ربما من تطور استهداف داخل
الاراضي الروسيه في موسكو تحديدا واعتراف
الجانب الاوكراني بهذا الاستهداف ما الذي
يعني
هو ترجمه لتصريحات صدرت من عدد من
المسؤولين وكان هناك اشاره واضحه جدا الى
فتره الانفجارات
يضاف الى ذلك الان المقاربه بدات اكثر
وضوحا الجانب الروسي يتحدث عن عمليه
عسكريه خاصه الجانب الاوكراني يتحدث عن
حرب روسيه على اوكرانيا وبالتالي المنظور
مختلف روسيا تعتبر انها تنفذ عمليه خاصه
مؤثره جغرافيا وبالتالي كان الجغرافيا
الجغرافيه روسيا الاتحاديه ما قبل شهر
شباط من العام الماضي خارج اطار المعركه
في المقاربه الاوكرانيه بدات الان اكثر
وضوحا خاصه مع تعثر الهجوم او المرحله
التمهيديه من الهجوم المضاد فبدات تبحث عن
وسائل ضغط اضافيه
لا تكون فاعله من وجهه نظر عسكريه لكنها
ستلقي بظلالها في الابعاد الاخرى عندما
يتم قبل
اسابيع محاوله الوصول الى قبه
قبلها الوصول الى قواعد عسكريه تقع الى
الشمال الى الجنوب الشرقي من روسيا الان
نتحدث عن
مسيرتين واحده على مقربه من وزاره الدفاع
هذه لها
تبعاتها على الصعيد السياسي والصعيد
الاجتماعي وهي رغم رغم صغر حجم العمليات
وعدم وجود تاثير عسكري لكنها تؤثر في
المجالات الاخرى خاصه البعد السياسي البعد
السياسي وهذه الجراه الاوكرانيه المتتاليه
بالمسيرات على العاصمه الروسيه موسكو هل
برايك باستطاعه روسيا الرد عليها وشاهدنا
بانها يعني طالما الحقت الامر بقصف ربما
قصفت البارحه اوديسا ولكن هل باستطاعتها
ان توقفها وان ترد عليها
يعني هناك فرق بين ايقافها او الرد عليها
ان توقف لا تستطيع لانه مساحه واسعه جدا
تنطلق من مناطق متعدده
بمبرات متباينه متباعده بتوقيتات مختلفه
يضاف الى ذلك وصلت الى قلب موسكو ولم يتم
اكتشافها وتم التعامل معها في المراحل
الاخيره اذا ايقاف لا اتوقع ذلك لكن ما هو
الرد الرد ياتي بالقصف الروسي سواء بالعام
19 طائره مسيره في اوديسيا بقصف البنيه
التحتيه ما تتعلق بالطاقه وهذا الامر
تابعناه بشكل
حثيز منذ الهجوم على جسر
كيرش او القرم في المره الاولى بدات تصعيد
الروسي وطال البنيه التحت التحتيه وكانه
كان عقابا على دكتور لواء فايز لكنه لا
يرضع اذا ما الفائده
من منظور عسكري يجب ان لا يرجع اذا كان
حقيقه من يعتقد الروس ان ذلك يردع
الاوكرانيين اعتقد ان قراءتهم عليها علامه
استفهام لماذا اوكرانيا دوله تعيش حاله
حرب فعليها وانا اتحدث من منظور عسكري
عليها ان تستخدم كافه الاوراق التي بيدها
صغيره ام كبيره وعن هذه الاوراق جدا ام
مؤثره نعم عن هذه الاوراق بالنظر الى انه
الهجوم المضاد الجانب الروسي يقلل من
القدرات الاوكرانيه في تحقيق اي انتصار
حقيقي في هذه العمليه التي تقودها بشكل
مضاد بينما الحلفاء يقولون ان اوكرانيا
استعدت 50% تقريبا من الاراضي التي فقدتها
سابقا تقييمك انت للوضع وتاثير هذه
العمليات التي تقوم بها اوكرانيا
يا سيدي وزير الخارجيه لامريكا تحدث امس
وهو من ذكر رقم 50 بالميه
والرياضيا الارقام صحيحه لكن فعليا لا لا
تعبر عن مسار المعركه يجب ان نميز ما بين
مناطق دخلتها القوات الروسيه
واثناء المعارك انسحبت منها وبالتالي انا
لا اضعها ضمن المناطق التي تم السيطره
عليها وصل الرقم الى تقريبا 25% من مساحه
اوكرانيا التي تبلغ
6000 كيلو متر مربع ووصل الرقبه الى اكثر
من 125 الف كيلو متر مربع ولكن معظم هذه
المناطق لم تسيطر عليها دخلتها على سبيل
المثال تشيرني هيف سومي غير ذلك ولكنها
تراجعت
تحت ضغط القتال فهذه لا يمكن ان
ادمجها في المناطق التي سيطرت عليها روسيا
الان اذا نظرت الى الخارطه ولا استطيع ان
اعطيك رقم دقيق ميه بالميه بسبب تحرك
العمليات انا اجريت بالامس قراءه
استشرافيه لحجم المساحه التي تسيطر عليها
روسيا الان وجدت تنحصر ما بين 58 الف الى
62 الف كيلو متر مربع لا تزال تحت السيطره
الروسيه بما فيها شبه جزيره القرم 27 الف
كيلو متر مربع شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه
الاضاحات من اعمال فايز الدوير الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي